the picture has an area of 80 square
centimeters what is the width of the
picture
so here's our picture this super fun
giraffe listening to music
and our pictures shape is a rectangle
and we're asked to find the width of
that rectangle
well maybe we don't know a special
formula or a special equation to find
width
but we do know one to find area of a
rectangle so let's use that formula and
see how it can help us
we know that area of a rectangle
can be found by multiplying the length
of the rectangle
over here the length
times
the width
so if we multiply the two side lengths
of a rectangle we get its area
and on this picture in this rectangle we
are told that our area is 80 square
centimeters so we already know the area
and we can use that to help us
we also know the length we're told that
this distance from here to here this
length is 10 centimeters
so the length is 10
times the width we don't know the width
that's what we're looking for
so what we do know though
is that we need our width to be a number
that when it's multiplied times 10
we get 80 for an answer so what number
times 10 equals 80
is 8.
8 times 10 equals 80.
so that means the width of our picture
is 8
centimeters
let's try one more
a rectangle has an area of 24 square
meters the width of the rectangle is 4
meters what is the length of the
rectangle
so this time we don't even have a
picture to look at but we have enough
information up here to solve this
again we can use our formula that tells
us area of a rectangle
is the length
times
the width
and we could draw this rectangle it
might be helpful to visualize it but i'm
going to show you here we can actually
solve it without ever even seeing the
rectangle
because we know the area is 24 square
meters
so the space the rectangle covers is 24
square meters
and the length we don't know the length
we're asked what is the length
but we do know
that the width is 4 meters
so our length has to be some number that
when it's multiplied times 4
we get 24 for the answer
and that number must be 6 because 6
times 4
equals 24. so the length of our
rectangle is 6
and in this case we're talking about
meters
meters